So far, in this course, we have considered software architectures.
Today, I would like to get into one particular kind of software architecture,
the architecture for distributed systems. And all this means is there's multiple
computers involved in providing whatever application technology system it's
supposed to. Moreover, we will consider heterogeneous distributed systems.
Systems in which the different computers are different kinds and
provide different capabilities. An example of this is a typical client server
system for example, insurance agents go out into the field,
they come to your house, they talk to you about various insurance options, and
they have their laptops. The laptops are connected to some server machine that,
understands the different forms you have to fill out, and the and
the rates involved in those in those particular contracts. And
ultimately if you sign up for a particular policy then the business
logic connects to a data base that stores the information about you and
your particular policy arrangements. In that particular situation,
there was a a database server machine, there was a web server
that was responsible for initiating and computing business logic.
And there were various web browsers running on laptop machines,
one for each agent. We'd like to look a little bit more in
how these particular kinds of systems are architected.